I am at one of the tallest wind farms in
Europe look at that isn't that beautiful
you can't tell right now but basically
when the cloud goes over that is so high
that it casts a shadow on the cloud as
its passing by what the reason I'm here
there's something you might not know
which is why when it's windy wind farms
aren't always on and rotating there are
a couple of reasons one is that wind
farms aren't built to take extremely
high wind speeds above 50 55 miles an
hour it starts get dangerous and this
beautiful thing could rip itself apart
so at high winds they slam the brakes on
and they stop them running because the
amount of energy would lose from doing
that is much less but the amount of
energy would constantly loose if you had
to build this thing to withstand
hurricane-force winds
the other reason is that the National
Grid can't cope with more than enough
power being dumped into it there are no
giant storage batteries that can hold
the entire output of a power station so
what happens is if the demand is low
then they will just turn off the ones
that are easy to turn off like this and
when demand rises again they will turn
on this and hydroelectric power plants
in order to deal with instant demand
nuclear coal gas or much hard to shut
down or much harder to start up and so
the National Grid keeps us balanced at
50 Hertz 50 cycles a second 16 American
50 in Britain by monitoring the plants
like this and turning that up and off as
need be and that is something you might
not have known
you